au petit matin ce bâtiment de brovary à
l'est de Kiev étant feu un hélicoptère
vient tout juste de s'écraser à
proximité d'un immeuble et d'une école
maternelle
nous étions en train de marcher et nous
avons entendu un bruit un énorme bruit
il y a eu des flammes l'hélicoptère
tournait sur lui-même
car tout le monde est à la maison à
cette heure-ci
malgré l'intervention rapide des secours
de nombreuses victimes sont à déplorer
des enfants mais aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur des Nice monastirski ainsi
que son premier adjoint qui se trouvait
à bord de l'appareil sur télégram le
président Zelenski a réagi au drame
aujourd'hui une terrible tragédie s'est
produite à brovary la douleur est
indicible j'ai donné l'instruction au
service de sécurité
ukrainien en coopération avec la police
nationale ukrainienne et les autres
autorités compét d'éclaircir les
circonstances de l'accident
pour l'heure les autorités ukrainiennes
envisagent toutes les pistes et se
gardent bien de faire référence à
l'envahisse russe l'enquête sur
l'accident pourrait prendre plusieurs
semaines